pas seulement pour les urgences.
Mais aussi pour avoir accès à u:
David Gentile.
laissent croire qu'on est
devant un hôpital québécoi
Mais en fait, nous sommes
à l'hôpital de Hawkesbury,
en Ontario.ésidente
de la MRC d'Argenteuil, Qc
- Moi, mon médecinon médecinon t
en Ontario. Je prends pas
de médecin au Québec parce
qu'il y en a pas.ès
de la moitié des patients
de cette urgence ontarienne
seraient québécois.
- C'est tout le temps
des réponses qu'on a au Québec s
les départements, pareil.
as de service au Québec.
- Certains patients ontariens
sont irrités de l'omniprésence
des Québpayés par le
Québec, ont permis de moderniser
l'Hôpital de Hawkesbury.
Dans la MRC d'Argenteuil,
au sud des Laurentides, 8 000
à 10 00s de santé en Ontario
l'an passé.
- Des ge- Des ge- Des gens commn
et William Horrocks.
Dans la MRC d'Argenteuil,
au sud des Laurentides, 8 000
des soins de santé en Ontario
l'an passé.
- Des gens comme Helen
et William Horrocks.ontarien pan
québécois est parti
à la retraite.
LYNN HORROCKS, résident
de Harrington et patient
de Hawkesbury en urgence,
en fait, on peut a
quelques heures, mais c'est pas
comme ici, dans la région,
passer 12 heures
dans la salle d'attente.
- William Horrocks a même subi
un remplacement de la hanche
en Ontario.os services de médece
spécialisée viennentde l'Ontari.
RICHARD FRANCOEUR, conseiller
municipal, Canton de Harring
pour être capable, une fois
par année, de rence, de rence, r
notre médecin.
- Richard Francoeur a aussi
la retraite de son médecin
québécois. Et il obtient aus
des services de médecine
spécialisée en Ontario.
- Éches comme ça, scanner,
les scans et tout ça, on va
en Ontario parce que les rendez-
vous sont beaucoup plus rapides.
- Entre 2017 et 2021, le nombre
de patientes d'Argenteuil quulte
en Ontario a augmenté de 55 %.éé
de 56 %. Vétuste et encombré,
l'Hôpit des établissements
ontariens.
Un phénomène qui touche auère
de Vaudreuil-Soulanges.PATRICK ,
MRC de Vaudreuil-Soulanges
va chercher des soins de santé
en Ontarnt,nt,nt,nt,nt,nt,
à l'hôpital d'Alexandria.
- Trouver un médecin de famille
l'accès à la médecinespécialisé.
Résultat : de 2017 et 2021 le
qui ont obtenu des services
ntario
a augmenté de 94 %.
Et en orthopédie, la hausse
La solutpar la
construction d'un nouvel hôpital
dans ce champs, où,e.
- On nous parlait à l'époque
de 2016. Là, on est rendus en
2022 et on n'en a toujours pas.
québécois du préfet de la MR
lui conseille simplement
de trave
d'aller soit au privé ou
un cardiologue à Hawkesbury.
Vous ave
qui te le suggère...
e,
Radio-Canada. Montréal.